[Music]
our most recent discovery from Ethiopia
is a fossil foot it's a partial fossil
foot that quite frankly is quite
shocking it's an extremely important
specimen because it opens up a window
into our past and how our foot evolved
that we didn't have before humans are
the only living mammals to walk on two
feet and it's a very peculiar way to get
around and it's actually the defining
characteristic of the human lineage is
walking on two feet as a researcher
that's interested and working backwards
and figuring out when did we begin to
walk upright how what stages did we go
through to walk upright the only
evidence that you really have as you've
got to go to Africa and you've got to go
where we go in Ethiopia and you've got
to search for the fossil
and that's what I do and that's what
Johannes haile selassie does and our
colleagues is that we go back we find
the fossils and that allows you to
actually reconstruct how these animals
walked and the steps the steps of the
work that they went through to get there
we know that the foot bones are younger
than three million four hundred and
sixty thousand years old and we know
that because we have demonstrated that
they lie above by about 27 meters a
volcanic tuff a layer of ash that was
erupted from the volcano and deposited
onto the ground and that is an example
of the volcanic touch right here from
the project area and what we see are a
lot of bits of pumice class of volcanic
glass but also within the tuff are
crystals minerals that crystallized
during the eruption when those minerals
lock in some radioactive elements at the
time that they formed and so the tuff
can be dated by the decay of those
radioactive elements and knowing how
much are present about them my initial
reaction when I first saw these foot
bones was one of quite frank surprise I
thought I knew what to expect at that
age because I had studied some of the
other Ethiopian fossils that are roughly
the same age when when I saw this I
realized the meaning these don't fit
and in fit
so these are the eight bones of the new
fossil and I've laid them out of here on
the table the original fossils are now
in Ethiopia at the National Museum in
Addis Ababa but these are extremely
detailed casts this has a big toe that's
standing off on the side very much like
this this is a chimpanzee foot than the
main character is this big thing its toe
it's big toe it's very much opposable
much like a thumb so this is a climbing
adaptation compare it to the human and
we are the only primates along with our
ancestors that have taken the big toe
that used to stand out on the side is
that grasping big toe and we've now
bring it into line with the rest of our
feet now to really appreciate the
significance of this foot and what it
tells us we have to compare it to some
other fossils that we've all read that
we've known about for years and I have
here casts of the very famous Lucy
fossil Lucy was living at the same time
that this animal was in fact very close
to one another what do we know about
Lucy well she sets the stage because
from Lucy we can tell this is her thigh
bone her left thigh bone we can tell for
several reasons her knee her hip that
she walked upright and essentially the
same manner that you and I walk upright
now we don't have much unfortunately of
Lucy's foot and this is another
individual of her species now this is
another big toe this is domed on the top
which allows you to say that this animal
the Lucy type of animal australopith
ACCA's was toeing off and had the same
amount of joint mobility that you know I
have and I want you to note that both of
them have joint surfaces that extend
onto the top now we go to the new foot
that was living at the same time as Lucy
Lucy's species no dome that alone tells
you this animal was still grasping and
it was not using its toe the way you and
I do but the Lucy specimen was so we
have a divergent type of bipedality one
the Lucy animal that is walking up
I committed to walking upright on the
ground but not this one this new
specimen is walking upright went on the
ground but doing it in awkward fashion
not like us but still maintained its big
toe grasping ability so we what we see
here two different groups and that was
one of the big surprises this fossil
foot raises questions in my mind about
the relationship between those feet the
organism that was walking around and the
environment we have found a lot of
fossils of Lucy like animals and this is
the first one that we've found that's
clearly so different why do we now find
it is it that we're beginning to piece
together a bit of environment this
wooded highly wooded environment that
the fossils of Lucy are not found in now
that we have this partial foot that
tells us so much of course what we want
to know is what's what what does its
head look like what do its teeth look
like what does its need look like what
does its angle look like what was its
pelvis like we don't know we don't know
but that I mean that's the exciting
thing and that's where we go back to the
field and look for these other pieces
until we find skulls and teeth of this
organism we were being cautious about
describing it as a new species is it
within the range of variation within the
other fossils I don't think so
I think it probably does represent a new
species but until we find more evidence
we're be cautious about it
[Music]